today i'm going to solve a mystery right
on par with the da vinci code how i went
from this one year ago
to this from uh soyboy beta to alpha
chad how i went from a bedroom crappy
studio to having a 10 million dollar
beard ladies and gentlemen welcome to
the 10 million dollar studio i'm your
host coffee zilla and today i'm going to
tell you my secret guys the secret to
getting the lambo in the garage right
because believe it or not i'm a lot like
you i eat my veggies i put on my pants
one suspender at a time right i take my
vitamins but there's one important
difference i
have 10 million dollars uh you may not
which is fine actually that's why i'm
here you might be short a few million
dollars but i have an answer for you
today how you can get the lambo without
having to lease it and it's a secret
that's gonna change youtube forever i
feel like no one knows about this except
for me and i keep trying to tell
everybody but nobody's listening so i'm
making this video so i never have to
explain myself again it's called virtual
production and it's basically well it's
basically green screens and you might be
saying steven what's new about that um
well mr know it all kind of a lot the
game has been changing in the green
screen world you might not know about it
and it's been changing the money
production problem on youtube in a way
that basically i feel like nobody's
figured out yet it's just me and i'm
trying to tell as many people as
possible about it when i can so story
time when i was starting out on youtube
much younger than this i quickly noticed
there was a problem on youtube well
there's several problems honestly i had
a lot of problems on youtube right you
know some of them were easy to solve you
know i had no personality that's easy
just make up a bunch of bad jokes and
fake laugh at them
but there are other problems that are
harder to solve one of them the money
production problem because you look at a
lot of like big youtubers today i don't
know if you've seen them lately they're
insane like gone are the days of low
budget sets and bad webcams there's
still a few og gyms out there but these
guys are the exception not the rule
nowadays you look around you got people
like mkb hd linus tech tips and they've
got these like million dollar sets going
on with staff and all these things to
make these videos that look well they
look great they look super high quality
but if you're just like a regular guy
starting out that's super intimidating
how do you get to that level it feels
like it's an uphill battle like at one
point this youtuber linus tech tips was
describing how after he bought his like
six figure seven figure warehouse he
then had to build a house inside of the
warehouse just to make it look like a
youtubery so we realized we're gonna
stop trying to build sets and we're just
gonna build a house so we found a condo
floor plan and we just built it in our
warehouse and this is the problem most
new youtubers face and the old answer to
this problem was we'll just get 10
million dollars and invest it in a 10
million dollar studio the new answer
ladies and gentlemen which i myself do
not use but uh you can
is green screen the answer is cgi yes
like computer generated graphics right
homegrown cgi ladies and gentlemen it's
come a long way in the past decade i
mean you remember the terrible stuff
we used to make back in the day wait a
second when was this movie made sorry
ladies and gentlemen bad cgi actually
still does exist uh just got word but
the ability for individual creators from
their basement to make amazing cgi now
has come a long way it's gone from
something that nobody but the biggest
studios in the world could consider or
dare invest in to something that indie
youtubers like ian hubert are doing now
and it looks awesome they're even
working on tech now where you don't even
need a green screen to even do it to
prove it here's a buddy of mine vikas
showing off some new tech he's been
working on i'm filming this for my
beautiful home definitely not my crappy
basement office
that was hastily arranged in the
pandemic and is next to a hot water
heater
are you guys getting it yet like this is
without a green screen and with a green
screen it looks even better maybe even i
don't know
indistinguishable from really being in
an office i i wouldn't know that
personally i'm just trying to tell you
guys um that this is gonna change what
it means to have a professional set
instead of buying a warehouse where you
spend a million dollars and then have to
build a house inside of your warehouse
there's gonna come a time where you can
throw up a green screen and look better
or even not have a green screen and look
better with more creative sets than you
could do for millions of dollars in real
life but okay that might sound
interesting to you but you're wondering
stephen
this newfangled attack why now why is it
coming around now weren't weren't we
always able to do something like this
why is the tech just now getting this
good well there's been some pretty
exciting stuff going around you may have
heard of like the mandalorian v tubers
have been exploding mocap suits are
getting good but i think in my opinion
the biggest shift that we've seen
is in realism with something called ray
tracing which is like a way to mimic how
light works in real life graphics have
like taken a quantum leap forward you've
probably already seen it like minecraft
with ray tracing on like looks like a
work of art but if you have stuff that
doesn't isn't just blocks it starts to
look like literally real life and at
some point it's gonna be hard to
distinguish computer-generated graphics
from real graphics and i'm not talking
like from a movie studio not a big
budget i'm talking about small youtubers
are gonna have their hands on this stuff
there's already huge communities in
things like blender and unreal engine
which are both free to use that are
coming up with insane results from the
comfort of their own home like here's an
example of a car chase scene by revvy
music and if you didn't know any better
you'd think this was real so let's put
this together the secret that no one
knows about on youtube yet is that two
things are intersecting and i want to
tell you guys about it i keep trying to
tell my friends nobody's listening to me
so i'm just going to make this video in
hopes that i can inspire somebody on the
one hand you have youtube pushing
towards higher production content where
creators are spending more and more
money to make themselves look more
professional on the other side we have
this new technology that's enabling
same or better looking visuals for a
fraction of the price those are going to
intersect and the conclusion is that
virtual production is going to be a game
changer and what i'm telling you guys is
get on the ground floor hey if you want
to pump the stock zilla you can be a
part but also still early into the party
if you want to make your own content
right i believe that this is going to
revolutionize the way people make video
content the way that cgi revolutionized
how people made movies 30 40 years ago
and you can be a part of it with very
little money which is awesome and you
can do that or you can have 10 million
dollars like me and just make your 10
million dollar studio the old-fashioned
way
your
same as so you're choices no you're not